in this video we're going to think about
how trade can alter the equilibrium
price and quantity in a given market so
what we see here as we like to do are
very simplified examples of markets in
various economies so first we have
country a and let's say it's the market
for widgets
and we're going to assume that country a
is not trading with anyone else so it is
an autarky a very fancy word which just
means that this country is operating
independently it's operating in
isolation and so you can see the demand
curve in this market in orange and we
can see the supply curve and you can see
when this country is operating in
isolation
this market for widgets has an
equilibrium price it looks like it's a
little bit under four dollars i'll just
assume that the price is in dollars per
widget and the equilibrium quantity
looks like it's about a little under
four units per whatever time period
we're looking at fair enough
now let's look at country b and let's
assume that they are also operating
independently it's an autarky in this
market and so here we can see a
different demand curve than what we saw
in country a and a different supply
curve
and notice they have a different
equilibrium price and quantity
so here the equilibrium price seems to
be a little bit over a dollar and the
equilibrium quantity seems to actually
be
not that different than what we saw in
the first country although in many
situations it could be very different
now let's imagine what would happen if
they opened up their economies to each
other
well then you would essentially
horizontally add these two demand curves
and you would horizontally add these two
supply curves to come up with a new
supply curve and a new demand curve this
is a little bit of a review of what
we've seen in other videos but notice at
a price of 5
in total no one's demanding anything no
quantity of these widgets and then at a
price of zero country a the market
there's demanding 15 and country b is
demanding five so in aggregate they are
demanding 20.
and similarly you can see that with
supply that at a price of five country a
will supply five and at a price of five
country b will supply 15 and so
together they will supply 20 units per
time period
and so we can view this right over here
as our supply and demand curves for the
combined markets because now they're
trading we are not in an autarky anymore
and notice what has happened
our equilibrium price is now someplace
in between these two equilibrium prices
so it looks like it's a little bit under
three dollars and our equilibrium
quantity
our equilibrium quantity is a little bit
under 10 units and so you might notice
some interesting things that are
happening what would happen from a
someone in country a's point of view the
people who are the the buyers the people
who are demanding this widget
well now instead of having to pay almost
four they're paying someplace in between
two and three this is the new
equilibrium
price if they were to open up their
economy
and so
what you have is is that this this
amount would be produced by in theory by
the domestic manufacturers so the first
let's call that two and a half units and
then the remainder where they're going
to get those units from well those are
going to be
imports
and let's look at the equilibrium price
on country b and country b was really
the lower cost producer and so country b
now we have a let's put it a little bit
over 2.5 so let's put it
right over there and so now you have a
situation where the suppliers in country
b are going to be producing a lot a lot
more than they were before and only this
amount is coming from their domestic
demand and then all of this amount right
over here that is being
exported
and if we're assuming that the world
economy is only made up of country a and
country b or that they're only trading
with each other these exports become
country a's
imports right over there
and so proponents of free trade will say
hey look the overall consumer surplus is
larger than the combined consumer
surpluses that we had before before you
had this consumer surplus in country a
and country b
it was all of this
but still this entire area is larger
than these two combined and you could do
it mathematically if you like calculate
the area of these triangles and if you
look at the producer surplus you'll see
a similar story the total producer
surplus of the combined economies now
this is going to be larger than this
producer surplus plus this producer
surplus
now some there will not always be
winners in this the winners here are the
demanders in country a because instead
of this little small
consumer surplus that they had before
now they have this much larger consumer
surplus right over there and then the
other winners are the suppliers in
country b because instead of this
producer surplus that they had before
they now have this producer surplus
but the losers in this situation are the
suppliers in country a who now have a
much lower producer surplus so their
triangle has shrunk to that right over
there and then the other losers in this
situation are the consumers in country b
who would have to pay a higher
equilibrium price and so their consumer
surplus
is
only this small triangle when before it
was this whole thing
so anyway the big takeaway here is is
that if you go from autarky to opening
up economies it can affect what the
equilibrium prices and quantities are
going to be and oftentimes or usually
it's going to increase your total
consumer and producer surplus although
there will be some winners and there
will be some losers